all right I should be live welcome
everyone I'm still in Nashville I have
two pending challenges one of which is
correspondence chess which I do not take
corresponds challenges and then the
other one disappeared soon I have zero
pending challenges but I do have tea
made some green tea round I would like
paper cups okay now I have a challenge
let's play living what does this name
start also I was debating whether to do
blindfold what's not to blindfold at
least for the first game
let's try pen Tomic let's play e4 hmm
maybe the sound isn't working okay there
won't be any sounds apart from my
commentary let's play do I play and we
have a petrov this is casual so no
rating on the line
let's take see what black is up to
Mustique you with a resub we open up the
chats hello to people in the chats
Bracken Dawson
kind of pink Jake welcome back everyone
cartoon cartoon lonely pawn do I play a
let's be aggressive let's play a
accosting gambit
now I play d4 type of opening that it's
tricky to deal with if black isn't so
well prepared on Bishop e7 interesting
debating Bishop c4 there's d5 so maybe
Knight c3 first preparing Bishop c4
looks interesting toilet noggin in the
chats with toilet noggin emotes
and al Rastro first time on the stream
nice yeah welcome to the live stream for
dog emotes tips eat on Mickey our jane
Wiese 2018
did I change the title pretty sure I
changed the title oh I forgot to change
this the go live notification I don't
know if I'll be doing some challenges
today but maybe I'll just be doing
general challenges uh Bishop e6 I mean I
could take and then the King is just
ripped from it's kind of safe place but
I don't really want to trade bringing
the King g6 I need to follow up so
Bishop takes c6 King gigs e6 yeah you
can still challenge me I'll type the
challenge command that should give you a
link make things easy
alright takes takes what to do g4 g5
there's d5 immediately the ideas of e5
hmm I think I'm gonna take play g4 I
like the idea of just removing the night
from f6 may be enabling later Queen g4
or Queen h5 ideas add mitla thanks for
subbing I'm using the blindfold setup
because I might play blindfold because I
have my hoodie my hoodie will act as a
blindfold
but this game I wanted to start at least
a bit more relaxing say hello to people
in the chats it's been a few days since
I've streamed on on my own channel
I was streaming on the u.s. chess
channel for this last weekend doing
commentary there's more people I don't
know how to say this name but it ends
with T I just call you T or maybe that
would be conflicting X I assume us
something assess us
T ling-ling Lowell says blindfold would
be good yeah maybe all I'll mix it up
play 1 blindfold game online blindfold
game you got Jess 7 months last stream I
did I played you got Jess to take down
the Kings Indian attack I attacked the
Kings Indian attack I've been getting
this question a lot do I like the newly
chess and I mean it's it wasn't like a
huge like groundbreaking updates like
everything's still quite functional
there's been minor changes with
responsiveness I like the fact that you
can kind of drag the board initially
nice it makes this stream layout a bit
easier ok I have to figure out how to
break through here at Queen h5 King g8 g
6 H 6 Bishop takes hsx G takes h6 Queen
takes h6 I'm almost mating but then
there's minus 6 event defending h7 but
then they have g7 in the end so maybe
it's not the end I win either when the
rook are made on h8 or promotes
okay let's have some fun I think I'm
gonna be sucking another piece
just uh take away black shelter jeez
Bates has to go prepare dinner for your
daughter
it'll watch later okay well have fun
preparing dinner guess sometimes there
are more important things in life than
watching these stream chess David Lange
gone 24 really need more YouTube videos
yeah I've been slow with a YouTube
content I mean all this traveling and
slower internet speeds makes it a little
book a little bit more difficult to
upload I have a lot of videos in the
pipeline it's just a matter of
scheduling them doing all the
descriptions etc let's have some more
fun
I mean I'm relying on my previous
calculation am threatening mates I have
ideas of g7 so g7 if Rick f7 it's made
in one rookie eight could be interesting
rook e8 Queen h8 king f7 still takes a
little bit of work I am down to pieces
I'm down to pieces four four pawns but
I'm almost mating
yeah nirvan Ramon's suggesting Queen d5
and taking on b7 maybe that was possible
at some point but I want to go for the
kill but how do I kill I need another
weapon maybe you're up to you on cuz
Queen eh a king of southern I don't see
anything I have a five nine eight seven
so maybe rook g1
can't be bad I mean support the pawn now
there's ideas of e5 and then f9 h7
Queenie sixes meets and black is a
little bit stuck like the bishop can't
move the knight can move allowing Queen
e6 I don't think tipsy ton suggesting
night h7 that yeah Queen e6 is a a major
idea lethal trigger didn't get the
notification you have to make sure
notifications are turned on you have to
follow me subscribe maybe I tried
setting up a discord bots to notify when
I go live but I'm not sure if it's
working I have to figure that out
cache Maggie and the chats with emotes
our life is pretty good
King f7 not a bad move or is it a bad
move and I have Queen e6 iv5 promoting
doesn't make any sense
Queen g6 might be reasonable to start
with I'll see if the king wants to make
a journey imagining King e6 Queen f5
king f7 Wow
yeah let's start with green i5 King f7
only legal move and then probably e5 the
Knights pinned and the like black would
like to move the bishop ooh maybe
there's takes takes and Bishop before
Queen d7 another move I mean I could
complete Queen g6 here yeah Queen g6
makes the most sense I don't want to
trade Queen's Knights still attacked by
the pawn so the fascinating position
King g8 very reasonable I was kind of
hoping for King e6 now I would play d5
King takes d5 would be pretty fun
alright what to do so if I take a clock
ticks back with check then maybe even
win this g7 so I could like go back to
where I came from I could leave all the
tension just queenside castle
trying to calculate your queen age six
ticks Queenie shaking f7 promotes
doesn't really lead to anything I mean I
like the idea of just castling like just
get the King off the e-file get the rook
on the D file align with the Queen
so if takes takes I attack the Queen and
the night's still ideas of this I'm
still down to pieces but it doesn't feel
that way well it's the compensation
there's also long term ideas of just
pushing a pawn there is this Carlson
there's a the Spitler Carlson gained a
few weeks ago or Carlson made its
fiddler with like two pawns like this
Anna King was in the corner it was
beautiful is everyone here a sub
actually there's a lot of subs in the
chat there's more subs than non subs Wow
probably kudos to John Davis for making
that happen I guess the one who studies
rocks is only nan sug unfortunately
alright whoa v6 looks really nice
threatening the Queen and threatening
mates in one and there's some funny idea
like if Queen takes the ship g5 Bishop
g5 I forgot about maybe I'm not winning
immediately stick with the Brooke take
with Queen
huh I thought you six was gonna be an
easy one completely miss Bishop g5 so
rook takes Queen takes c6 yeah it's
still gonna be a fight and I could take
on g5 of the Queen Queen Dixie six maybe
that's better
it feels weird like my Queens hanging
but if takes and I take the Queen and
all in the Knights and then I'll be up
like three pawns you're not a sub on
YouTube yeah everyone can be a sub on
YouTube just click the button it's
familiar shadow says John Davis started
my sub but you're already like a three
month subscribers you have the knight
next to your name so if you started it
maybe you continued it or maybe he
continued it all right I'm up three
pawns I went from being down two pieces
for four pawns to now being up three
pawns okay let's what do I want to do
reinforce probably reinforce the jeep on
I don't know if I've hit a 40,000 off to
check I do have a window or a tab open
hey oh it's close it's gonna happen like
next minute or two minutes
nirvan Raymond says I think you were
lost yeah I mean sometimes that's what
you have to do to win quickly
this is ketal lost position which is
really questionable but difficult for
the opponent to play wait rookie ones
coming
Akemi to the 94 chuck
let's play a this move hit the Knights I
want to remove the night and just start
pushing the pond oh oh hey forty
thousand and one thanks guys for subbing
on youtube it's a nice number I try not
to like check the sub count so often but
it's nice when we see numbers like that
alright uh ninety five wait he wants to
win the pawn maybe rookie five looks
nice
all these emotes thanks guys for all the
support I really appreciate it I mean
YouTube has been a big kind of driver
for growing with twitch audience as well
life is very good
I still have t probably left the teabag
in too long that's he's still good my
player Kings gambit maybe could take
opening recommendations
yeah the sub command shows you how to
subscribe on Twitch the youtube command
will take you straight to youtube thanks
Braden Laughlin appreciate Braden
Laughlin was joins the the viewership
pretty early like I like this is still
very new for me like the whole a whole
idea of making video contents it's only
within the last like year and a half
and I really only started being active
on YouTube because of the st. Louis
chess club videos like I did videos for
them they got good kind of feedback and
then people started subscribing to me
even when I wasn't making videos because
I was responding detect to comments in
the st. Louis videos so it was a sign
that that there was some potential okay
let's take up on I'm gonna play 96 next
and win the night's probably just
simplified to a King pawn ending you can
torture black a little bit King h7
expected yeah just show some technique
st. Louis is a reason I wanted you as a
coach analysis was always so clear and
precise I appreciate that
and honestly like I I remember like
doing some of the early st. Louis
lectures and being very close to asking
or requesting that they not be recorded
because I was really nervous in
delivering at least the first few but um
yeah over time I guess I got more
comfortable all right I really didn't
pay attention to time but thankfully I
have enough time this is not stalemate
my arrow game is on point and so many
nice comments in the chat it's hard to
read them all hello ocean floater from
UK nice yeah I'm streaming of European
friendly time it's just approaching 1:00
p.m. Central Time
which means it's probably like somewhere
in the evening in Europe not too late
hopefully
I have to check out of my hotel room in
one hour
so one more hour slept count is
increasing okay I'm trying not got too
wrapped up in the number there
let me get feedback from the chat I
could do a blindfold game or I could do
a normal game pretty far away from
passing agony there and I don't really
treat it as a competition but maybe
that's that's a goal
someday I'll reach the the Agra Dimitar
heights blindfold no blindfold please do
blindfold normal blindfold everyone it
keeps alternating between blindfold no
blindfold actually normal seems a bit
more popular but some people really want
mindful like there's there's more
comments that say blindfold please
rather than normal please which means
people who want me to do blindfold are a
bit more Polites whoa it's bits from
toilet noggin saying normal well this is
number five to six five not sure if
there's any significance it's May it's
May 13th five to six five okay I'll do
one more normal game because now people
are saying normal please I do appreciate
politeness and bits okay
I'm not on chrome chrome was being
really laggy let's play trying to find
like a new name I don't recognize let's
play clamp clamp
bribes always work but next next game
will be blindfold so I'll do two normal
more warming up my my chess abilities
let's play a Sicilian and I will
guarantee next game okay I don't have a
blindfold maybe I could call reception
and ask for a blindfold that'd be weird
that would probably be weird
okay I'm playing a dragon thankfully I
have a hoodie well I could call
reception and ask for a sleep mask or
maybe I could start by asking for a
blindfold if they sound confused refer
to a sleep mask but I'm checking out it
I'm not sleeping so yeah it's not the
best idea
f3 so early f3 so early is actually main
line cuz he doesn't want me to play
Knight g4 so we're having a main line
dragon yeah this is when they Castle
before playing Bishop to c4 then it's a
nice line to play Bishop e6 preventing
Bishop c4 preparing Queen a5 wait can i
play Queen a5 immediately Queen 85
Knight d5
I don't have so much experience in the
dragon I really shouldn't just know the
slime queen 85-95 Queen takes detune I
take C seven it's kind of annoying okay
I'll play Riki yet because I don't want
to deal with any messiness and now we'll
play a queen a fine those ideas here of
there's a few ideas okay pushing the B
pawn rook c8 and maybe sacking and
winning a two if white ever plays a3
then before it could be a nice break
looking at attics but I don't think
anything works takes takes know also g5
is hit by the Queen but all right 97 to
do what I need to do hex or is a quacks
there's no you after the cue you
violated the rules of spelling but
thanks for the sub two months does music
distract you and playing oh no well it
depends on the music but I think it
would be more distracting for the
viewers
now I've debated whether to put music on
streams there's a few issues one issue
is like copyrights sometimes twitch will
mute the stream afterwards and then also
everyone has a different taste in music
so white wants to destroy me like h5 in
Queen h2 is on the horizon
let's just play rook regazzi AIDS or
Casey it maybe Rock a c8 this rook might
be important and defending now a6 I have
to move quicker this is blitz maybe
Knight c4 might see for a fortnight or
95f for night c4 maybe rook c5
interesting and b4 let's play rook c5
this could just be a blunder but it
looks interesting
I want to make white think I'm also may
be discouraging h5 because it rook takes
g5 and I want to play I have two ideas I
want to play rook c8 and I want to push
the pawn and I also want to move quicker
Bishop h3 is taking very little risk
should probably take that let's play 95
OC for this looking juicier like it be
for Queen digs a three ticks and then
Knight c4 Queen C 1 this should be just
crushing 4 black I'm actually pretty
content if we trade on e6 okay Knight c4
Oh Queen d4 forgot about that
King g8 is necessary King f8 would have
gotten made it in 1 so we're both trying
to attack I mean white storm looks scary
but this night combined with this Queen
also may be scary
InfoSec thanks for subbing for four
months this is very sharp position I
don't play the dragon too often but I'm
trying to get comfortable in these these
sharper positions usually comes down to
whose attack is quicker who can keep
initiative create stronger threats I'm
not sure what my thread is I mean
there's simple tactical idea a knight
takes a three followed by taking on c3
why is my elo solo I probably do two
tilts also I was flying on my phone in
San Francisco I was like on the train
playing in like some me chess arena I
think there was one game I started and
it didn't alert me and then I just
flagged it was really unfortunate h5
okay so ignoring everything I mean white
wants to destroy me
Knight takes 83 B takes 83 Queen takes
c3 takes takes 2 X takes rook age 16 g7
rook da chuan or g8 what else to do
Queen b6 is a move threatening mates but
then the knight can move up in the night
Knight takes a 3 Queen b6 or Queen b6 is
night a four that could be troublesome
I also have e5 here let's take first so
I gotta play quick this might be a
consideration for white okay yeah so
this is what I was calculating after
take sticks takes takes rook h6 King f7
our King g7 better rook dh1 I have
rookie eights I think this is important
move because we're cage Savin King f8
and this pause defended this one's
defended the spawns attacked on a3
there's ideas of rooks c4 we are
probably going into this line yeah if I
didn't have rook G eights then there
could be issues like white would be
penetrating Lonnie Ella's thanks for
subbing work age 16 g7 jocks upon I
don't see how I mean maybe there's some
idea for whites but it's not easy so I
don't want white to take and open up the
the rink I don't want to take here and
open up that file so let's play this
move I feel like this is pretty stable
now spawn still attacked I'm not scared
about five and this rooks really passive
but does hold things together this works
active
maybe if the King belongs on d7 and then
the rook should swing in and then my
rocks can start coordinating play this
first I want to target c3 yeah now
there's no defense to c3 take with which
rook maybe take with this rook rook c2
coming mmm it's very close to mates I
want to play rook a3 and rook c4 or
rogue a3 and rook t2 this is a made
threats that was nice
it's nice to me in the center rook
ending still waking up but that was a
was pretty smooth the attack led to
simplification which led to an end game
I think those calculation was important
even in this position it's why if you
play these short positions you really
have to calculate concrete lines
[Music]
cuz it looked a little bit scary if I
don't have worksheets then like whites
actually threatening whites threatening
force made here there's a may than three
threats
I think grouchy it's the only way to
defend just society what's up yeah you
were gift to the sub
some people were gift to the sub who
weren't watching the stream because John
Davis gifted more more subs than their
work like concurrent viewers okay so
we're gonna do a blindfold game what
happens if you took a three after pawn
takes the night
pawn takes and night oh this position so
if I take a three here I was really
concerned about this I mean maybe I ever
gave five threatening mates it I don't
think it works so like Y can take with
Chuck King f7 g6 I'm getting mated or
queen I fake Queen eight shades and rook
b5 check ID there's Knight takes be fine
so I was looking for stuff like that but
the Knights is it's sufficient in
defending what's the best place to buy
my London system 8020 course the best
place is through my unique link because
I think I that my unique link gives me
the like biggest cuts sometimes it
depends on math but you can use a London
command actually don't have the London
course in my book recommendations
because it's a video course but moobot
just shared the link to it if you're
interested
as a beginner would you recommend me to
read the chest book or watch YouTube
videos I get this question a decent
amount and my usual answer is you have
to understand how you learn best
different people different players have
different learning styles some players
are are more adept to reading books
other players learn better from from
watching videos so if you're not sure
what's best for you you want to maybe
try both sometimes it's also just about
finding the rights there are resources
right content but self-awareness is a
very important thing to improving at
anything just learning what works for
you double-o P black double o with 100
bits yeah this is a slightly normal
streaming time there's a lot of that
okay there's a lot of comments it's hard
to keep up with everyone
Shivam Bosman soul asking did I learn
from books yeah I grew up with a good
number of books I don't think there's
been almost any books I've read front to
back but I've had a variety of books
I've kind of used as reference or used
to solve tactics or look at high level
games or look at annotations well
sometimes it's nice to build up a
library and then have have resources to
study when you're when you're looking to
study different areas so I have a bunch
of endgame books bunch of books on high
level games some opening books what do I
think of tall I took a picture with tall
I went to LA via I have a photo with me
and tall it was a statue of tall but
maybe I can find it it's on Flickr
my flickr link is just Eric Rosen
photography if you scroll down go to
albums and scroll down there should be
an album called Latvia trying to find it
on my phone hmm actually not seeing it
oh it's actually a long time ago here we
go okay if you guys want to see a photo
of me and tall it's just of his head
I can't even zoom in on this picture
it's me and tall anyway okay let's move
on I have 23 pending challenges let's do
a blindfold name I'll play it was a
recent sub Oh are beasley subs two
months thanks are beasley appreciate
that I'm not using my extension plugin
because I'm on Safari
so let's play who can I have a nice game
with let's play or Seto and let's turn
on speech synthesis sounds yeah I
changed the voice but okay for the time
activated let's click this thing okay
good luck
I'm gonna look at the keyboard though so
505 Bishop c4 Knight f6 sorry so for the
duration of this game I won't be looking
at the chat you guys have to behave so
the the double Bishop opening what is
this Bishop c4 probably a Bishop c5
probably 9 f3 let's play h6
ship III it's hoping for a Bishop h4
then I would play g5 hmm let's take h3
so plane quickly doesn't want me to play
Knight g4 wanna play I'm playing nine
eight five when a five looks reasonable
I just just want to get rid of this
Bishop you played a 3 a 3 haha it's a
mouse lip I can't I don't know how to
give a take back blindfolded I'm sorry
too quickly
probably pre-move day 3 at the wrong
time that was quick or Osito yeah there
is no increment in that game so a time
scramble maybe would have been tricky
it's the one thing like if you Mouse
slip I probably would have given a take
back if that we were normal
I know if people heard that I was
actually kind of strange when I turned
down the volume it was like an echo of
9f seven okay I'll do one more blindfold
because that was ten moves let's play
let's play let's play stavros yeah I'm
playing another leech as patron Stavros
chats Z ganas sounds Greek as my
opponent here sure where is my sound
sound have to message t-bolts about this
thing okay
my phone's not here I'm aborting let's
do another challenge
um let's pick whatever the largest
object is so Batman T chickpea puffs
what's the largest largest object ocean
anything larger than an ocean no let's
play ocean where is ocean ocean flow
there okay rated 1099 reminds me of
taxes okay beautiful goodbye world
wait you find e55 complicated position
b3 b3 novelty just want to follow
opening principles play 96 just
developing attacking upon I would draw
arrows it's difficult Bishop b2
attacking my pawn I could take on e4
wait 94 rights 84 why can't I take
Knight e4 wait I'm so confused
oh I didn't play that at six yet I paid
Nick c6 let's play d6 we forgot the
position after like three moves so I'm
defending the pawn 1 develop my
LightSquared bishop this is a 3-2 game
okay there's a b5 play Knight of 6 now
attacking me for me d3
I want to be creative weights want to
play like Knight g4 let's play Bishop g4
h3h3
reasonable move are we gonna see g4
attacking my bishop if he plays g4 maybe
I take on g4 with a knight would
probably dubious so d 4 d 4 might be
playable it's taken my Knights pinned on
C said no e4 is actually hanging g7 is
hanging I think Queenie choose a move
Queenie - maybe I cast g4 okay happy to
play Bishop g6 supporting my nights in
g7 it's not taken okay
I guess the pitcher takes g7 I could win
have to let's fight night c5
so I want upon ready to castle white
expanded maybe a little bit too early
yeah I either want a castle next or play
queen at six next pretty sure this night
it's - still on b1 whoa okay let's
castle maybe I could have considered h5
it's still gonna try and attack on the
Kings side let's play Queen Queen f6 the
queue is always hard to type Queen Oh
what did I do what no what happened
where'd my king go what what did I do
I played f6 I typed it how do i type it
in the search bar okay rook e1 Queen f6
all I've clicked tab and then I typed in
f6 instead of Q oh no okay minor
distraction
well I'm using the rook on a 1/3 C 3 so
defending the rook let's play rook e8
rookie oh I have to specify which rook
rook f8 pretty move rook e8 ok so up
upon solid controlling the e-file next
move maybe Bishop to e4
also d3 is a weakness I have 93 I Ono 93
Bishop 63 so maybe a six first ID for
interesting like probably Knight takes
d4 wait Knight takes d4 Bishop takes
Knight f3 hmm seems so close to working
90 for ID for ticks ticks and f3 this
looks like too much fun either three
king h1 Bishop b4 yeah that looks like a
lot of fun
please take my rook oh oh actually now
my rook and Knight are both attacked
I have 94 here I 94
now if white takes my rook it's me than
to believe Queen e1 defending also
paying my knight to the brook and my
rooks attacked let's play c66 attacking
the bishop
Oh d4 is hanging to so I could just take
d4 fish of t-34
so I'm hitting the bishop wait it's just
so upon on c3 no because you took back
on d4 so I'm hitting the pawn are the
rook on a1 and the bishop on d3 also
pressuring the palm in f2
Oh 92 defending everything except the
bishop Queen d3 if you take sunny for
all plate there should be 4 do you one
wait so I have an i-94 work on Yeats
bishop on g6
I can't move my knight I could move back
to have six maybe could play f6 f6 is
kind of interesting f6 f6 defending my
rook with a bishop which basically on
pins and nights so now there's ideas of
like Knight c3 or Knight g3 wait what
where's the king my queens on d4 oh no
it's on d3 I thought that pawn was
pinned
oh so f3 I can I can play Knight c3
attacking the rook and the Queen
my bishop better be on g6 queen f4
that's good sign
point 92 let's play Queen e3 next move
will be 91 let's play Bishop at e3 I
just want to go for the kill
gonna take that unless there's something
stronger let's play Bishop f4 always
play Bishop left one Queen takes F 1
let's play Queen c2 wait where's my
Queen Queen d2 now maybe rookie two
trying to meet probably g5 and queen of
Florida g5 always play g5 shout out to
love-hate chess before queen up for
mates queen for a chess weeb what's up
thanks Jeff sweet for stopping by
alright that was difficult I don't know
how I I dunno how I open the new tab to
be careful pressing tab
okay well I got raided shall deflection
with a sub G embed Feingold with a raid
I'd even know this Lorraine
we scroll up here I can't even scroll up
far enough or maybe I can raid with 2:18
welcome Ben Feingold people what you
call Ben Feingold fans Feingold errs he
needs a name for his like his audience
alright so many comes to reading chat
it's difficult
all the Feingold graders are gonna hate
f6 f6 was a nice move at some point I
got raided and then played f6 to replay
that alright I'm checking out of my
hotel in 26 minutes mmm that's probably
my my only blind pool actually that was
the second blind pool game that's my
last pine pool game of the stream oh
let's play another game though let's
play the highest rated player highest
rated player 1800 1900 1900 anyone over
2000 oh 24:01 okay let's play chickpea
puffs alright
playing chickpea puffs higher either
than me this is casual though so there's
no rating points on the line is my
opponent here I might have to abort
where am I always asking that question
I'm in I'm in Nashville come back to st.
Louis
alright back in st. Louis by the end of
the day hopefully assuming my flights
not too late
you got just with 100 bits okay we're a
boarding because my points not here
sadly let's turn off the speech
synthesis okay
and let's play let's play let's play the
next highest rated player who do I play
mouse in the house 1943 yeah let's play
mouse in the house let's play efore yeah
I do have a list of book recommendations
on my websites it's a relatively small
list so that I'm sure there's a lot of
books out there which are still good
which aren't on the list there's also a
much longer list on the perpetual chess
podcast websites where you see what top
players recommend what books so I'm
playing pawn gianni this Queen a4 line
is a bit tricky while the players will
stop to think here it's not entirely
clear how Locke deals with this simple
threats on Bishop d7 is playable hello
to karma let's play Queen d1 so this is
a gambit line Black's acting upon for
some initiative
I'll beat with a sub thinks all Beats or
Al beats play Bishop c4 the one issue
with the structure is it's hard to
develop these Queen side pieces quickly
so I probably want to play d3 and Bishop
g5 92 and do things
you know Bishop g5 coming next oh no
Kings gambit I apologize is that a
frowny face that's probably a frowny
face all right let's play Bishop g5
feeling relatively comfortable am i
acquainted with yasser uh yeah I know
Yasser see uh sir
a good handful of times throughout the
year usually in st. Louis always
friendly sometimes plays crazy house on
Leech s ok so we're trading can't
complain
we'll try and keep it positional on the
play rook he1
I would not concern myself a dancer at
least in most situations thinking about
this maybe I'll play g3 first I want to
play Queen III hitting hitting both rook
pawns before is reasonable maybe let's
take probably gonna take here ideas of
Bishop g4 I'm hitting both responds with
the Queen oh but this fall's defended so
I'm only hitting a7 put the rook on d4 a
black hole probably play f5 maybe one
plan is Bishop b3 and push the C pawn
also ideas of lifting the rook mhm for
maybe just trying to blockade fix black
spawns on light squares keeping the time
advantage
what's a natural move in chess it's
actually kind of hard to define what's a
natural move it's a move that like is
very kind of instinctual or you if you
play chess for a certain amount of time
you'll understand kind of types of moves
which are just kind of harmonious in the
position usually involves making some
some improvements not causing any like
conflicts between your pieces so blocks
act upon to ruin my structure play
Bishop C - Lu - GG thanks for solving
three months type f3 and the Bishop do
you want yeah I was considering f3 I
think at some point so the Bishop t1o
that with him g3 yeah I didn't want to
play off three but g3 was a bit tender
okay this is interesting maybe not
necessary though this is also
interesting
hit the palm this is a little bit
uncomfortable defend my rook so the
bishops not pinned and we're having a
time scramble it's a pretty slow time
scramble I just till I blunder or that I
find a genius idea if he takes the rook
I I forced me this is nice
this accidental sacrifice okay GG Apple
chess welcome I think I'll be ending
things shortly don't have any tips for
weak players to get better in a quickest
way you have to play a lot and sometimes
you have to lose a lots but you have to
go over your losses and strive to play
against stronger players there's a lot
of people they they want to play players
maybe their level or below them because
they want to win a lot but if you
constantly players about play players
above you it will have I think a
beneficial impact on your game as long
as you don't get too discouraged
thanks for the bits double P black
double O trying to bribe me with bits
what's your twitch or what's your
elitist name double o P double o need a
nickname for you or do you have a we
just named I could command F oh oh oh
that was obvious I actually I can't play
this time control I would play you but I
check out in 17 minutes so let's play
uploads game let's play Dadon
do I play blindfold let's let's play one
more black for game sounds see Paul
really needs to fix this all right good
luck opponents goodbye Ted three minutes
no increments Scotch open English
couldn't be aggressive I want to play c3
I forgot to check his rating d6 it's a
sign that it's not too strong CD for
like the opening have some Center have
some development I got some tactics soon
mmm
let's castle castle castle g5 pin denied
I want to play 95 Nexus h6 Bishop g4
wrong yeah let's play let's play 95
no not 95 no Bishop f6 how bad is a 6
that was a type slip 58 rook t1 rings Oh
Brooke Brooke Brooke 81 materials equal
you see 3
VTech c3e takes me four blocks winning
upon if let's play let's play CD for
seat XD for we're up texting for they
shall be fine
wrote xt-1 rocked XD one rock the aid
Roxie 1 white 1 minute 41 seconds black
two minutes zero seconds eight six King
f1 King f8 key to down the pawn only
done one pawn I'm trying to remember
where all the pawns are a to e4 f - g -
h - knight on c6 work on g6 pawns a7b
senses on like before
Oh so talking the bishop my Bishop b3
Rick t3 key me too
c6 Roxy for hit the Knights thanks the
a6 is kind of random f4 a five-way other
pawns not hanging b5 let's play rooks
you weren't
Roxy f66 play g4 to late grub quickly
585 F tech c5 f taxi 5 ok thanks
your h6 let's play rook see to Roxy to
5k me for 400 where does my bishop move
as my bishop trapped my bishops trapped
no I have bishops year it's Bishop
cheats
King better be on e7 96 go Bishop e6
mm-hmm King out fine thanks h6 h4 h4 g6
chick Kenny for 7 wide oh my gosh
look 0 minutes 46 seconds for I don't
have enough time King c7 Brooksie for
Roxy no take that thanks opponent okay
now I'm gonna I'm gonna play because I'm
low on time
and I'll try and fights we need this
okay I'm cheating a little bit by
peeking but I'm still probably gonna
lose on time or maybe not maybe I'll be
fast I was a good move no GG well played
I was rough I was really rough the game
was actually interesting
I meant to play Knight d5 maybe five how
does a fun game though than the end game
when you played a four I took me a while
to realize Bishop g8 it's only square
and I think King f8 actually traps the
bishop here Wow I miss King f8
my opponent was so nice to give me a a
take back but it didn't really matter
yeah these pawns were strong I should
probably move planking c3 be a closer
fights
alright well having the end things
because I have to check out and I have
to pack in the next nine minutes so
thanks guys for watching appreciates
people watching stopping by have a
headache
it's bit too much blindfold chess Pasha
goes streaming let's red pesca
I think pashka is reaching a point where
he's just like stronger than me
I can proving so quickly all right
raiding pashka have fun guys thanks
again for uh for allowing me to break
this amazing number next stop next stop
for 2014 and then eventually 50,000 okay
I'll see you guys in the future and my
next stream will be in st. Louis goodbye